antes de pasar a otro tipo de funciones
tomemos la derivada parcial de nuestra
función f x 10 del vídeo anterior
o la derivada parcial de z respecto de y
en esta ocasión en el vídeo anterior lo
hicimos para x
ahora vamos a calcular la derivada
parcial de zeta respecto de ella
ahora estamos diciendo cuánto cambia z
al variar de verdad entonces x es
constante por lo tanto la derivada de x
cuadrada respecto de i es cero así que
ignoremos la ahora el término x x es una
constante por lo tanto al multiplicar
esto sale de la derivada verdad entonces
la derivada de x de respecto ayer
simplemente es x
y finalmente cuál es la derivada de
cuadrada respecto de y pues es 2 y
entonces como pueden observar es
simétrico lo que habíamos obtenido en la
derivada parcial respecto de x verdad
sólo que aquí es x más 210 y bueno eso
es porque la ecuación original es
bastante simétrica la x y la ye más o
menos hacen la misma el mismo papel
verdad ahora escogemos déjenme de borrar
esto porque porque vamos a elegir un
punto distinto para para graficar la
pendiente ok
borremos todo esto esto también no creo
que sea necesario incluirlo así que lo
que vamos a hacer es elegir el que el
punto x sea igual a que será x igual a
punto 3
también que sea igual a punto 3
ahora cuando x es igual a punto 3 y es
igual a punto 37 es igual a bueno punto
3 al cuadrado más punto 3 por punto 3
más punto 3 al cuadrado 7 es igual a
punto 3 al cuadrado por 3 verdad que es
punto 27 entonces cuál es la derivada
parcial de z respecto de x en este punto
es decir fsv x en punto 3.3 equivale a
bueno sustituir punto 3 en esta ecuación
verdad esto es punto 9
porque es dos por punto 3 que es punto 6
puntos 3.9 ahora la parcial de f
respecto de y en el mismo punto pues
también va a valer punto 9 verdad son
exactamente las mismas cuentas ahora
vamos a ver si podemos visualizar lo
vamos a regresar la gráfica de la
función ok entonces es esto de nuevo
esta es la gráfica de la función zeta
gge x cuadrada más x yemas de cuadrada
verdad y esta caja es el dominio que
elegimos para que la elegimos así porque
se está crece comienza a crecer muy
rápido así que aquí se puede ver
claramente lo que quiero mostrarles
entonces quiero mostrar qué pasa en el
punto en donde calculamos las derivadas
en este punto se está vale punto 27
verdad así que esto nos ayuda a decir en
qué punto estamos trabajando estas dos
líneas y si quieres verlo así es la
línea donde ya es constante verdad una
de
y la otra es donde x es constante así
que la pendiente en esas líneas es
simplemente las derivadas parciales que
ya calculamos verdad esta es la línea
tangente relativa x que podríamos verla
como si mantuviéramos que constante
entonces esta es la línea tangente
manteniendo ayer constante por otro lado
esta es la línea manteniendo a x
constante y como dijimos en el último
vídeo pues hay una infinidad de líneas
tangentes en ese punto así que tenemos
que elegir una dirección en el plano xy
en donde vamos a derivar por eso fue que
empezamos con las derivadas parciales
esta gráfica verdaderamente ésta está
muy bien desarrollado este software
incluso podemos acercar la imagen
muy bien un poco más ok ahora quiero
moverla a la parte interesante vamos a
trasladar esto
perfecto esta es la parte que es
interesante ahora vamos a rotar la un
poco verdad verdaderamente podemos hacer
magia con esto esta es la recta tangente
esto muestra que la parcial de la
función con respecto a y la pendiente es
punto 9 y esta línea muestra que la
parcial de la pendiente perdón la
derivada parcial de la función o la
parcial de zeta
respecto a x también es punto 9 en ese
en ese punto que es x igual a punto 3.3
iceta era punto 27 correcto entonces si
la rotamos para ver más de forma más
clara que es lo que está pasando
allí se ve muy bien aquí se ve que ambas
líneas son tangentes en ese punto de
hecho son dos líneas definen un plano y
el plano definido por esas dos líneas o
cualquiera dos líneas que sean tangentes
en ese punto define un plano tangente a
la superficie sólo tiene un plano
tangente aunque dentro de ese plano hay
una infinidad de líneas tangentes verdad
de todos modos esto es lo divertido de
los gráficos no podemos ver muchísimas
cosas desde allí hasta con colores
verdad eso es acostumbrarse también un
poco a la matemática vamos a borrar toda
la pantalla vamos a hacer algo que a lo
mejor podría confundirte pero debe
quedar claro cómo hacer esto así que
vamos a hacer ya ejercicios prácticos
para calcular derivadas parciales y
bueno tal vez veamos alguna forma de
verlo gráficamente tomemos esta función
x x x coseno de y muy bien y ahora vamos
a tomar la derivada parcial de f
respecto de x en cualquier punto xy esto
que va a ser bueno como tratamos allí
como constante este co seno de y sólo es
constante y sale de la derivada verdad
así que lo ponemos al frente y decimos
que la derivada parcial respecto de x va
a ser coseno de y por la derivada de los
de los demás verdad así que coseno
después depende de quien sea
no se puede ser pi lo que sea pero aquí
es una variable ahora derivamos x por
seno de x y lo que vamos a tener que
usar es la regla del producto así que la
derivada de x es 1 que multiplica seno
de x y ahora sumamos x por la derivada
de seno
x por coseno de x verdad entonces
tenemos coseno de x que es la derivada
de seno verdad multiplicando a x es la
primera expresión ahora sí expand si
desarrollamos todo entonces la derivada
parcial de f respecto de x es igual a
y hacemos la propiedad distributiva y el
seno de x por coseno de iu
muy bien más ahora esté sumando lo
multiplicamos por co seno de iu y nos
queda x coseno de x coseno de iu
nada complicado verdad solo te tienes
que dar cuenta de que ya es una
constante muy bien ahora tomemos la
parcial de efe pero ahora en la
dirección y cómo cambia efe al variar ya
entonces la derivada parcial de f
respecto de y en cualquier punto xy es
la derivada de esta función donde ahora
vamos a considerar a x como una
constante verdad entonces si x es
cualquier número por ejemplo pónganle 5
lo que sea pues eso sale de la derivada
porque es un producto de una constante
verdad así que esto no se altera y sólo
nos falta derivar la otra parte respecto
de y en donde de cualquier modo es la
derivada de coseno de y es menos x menos
seno de verdad así que ponemos el menos
y con amarillo escribimos seno de iu
ahí lo tenemos vamos a hacer otra
función borremos todo de hecho ahora
vamos a agregar más variables
ok digamos para que te acostumbres a la
notación diferente x es igual a al
cuadrado x no lo sé
a cuadrada por quien por ver a la al
cubo y luego por ser un medio
vamos a derivar x que es nuestra función
respecto de a que es una de nuestras
variables bueno todas las demás letras
son constantes así que la derivada
parcial de x respecto de a es 2a verdad
y esto lo multiplicamos por b al cubo
sea la un medio que son mis constantes
de hecho puedo quitar los paréntesis a y
ahora calculemos la derivada parcial de
no deben de x respecto de b y ahora las
otras letras son constantes y
simplemente hay que derivar ve entonces
copiamos a cuadrada sea la un medio y
derivamos b al cubo que es 3 x b
cuadrada que reagrupando simplemente nos
queda 3a cuadrada de cuadrada salón
medio acomodándolo de forma agradable
como ves no es nada de nada difícil sólo
nos faltaría ver la derivada parcial de
x respecto de ese entonces todo eso
queda constante a cuadrada y b al cubo y
multiplicó por la derivada de s a
medio que es un medio por sea la menos
un medio verdad o bien podemos
escribirlo como a cuadrada de al cubo
entre dos se raíz de ser verdad que es
sea la menos un medio de cualquier forma
se me acaba el tiempo así que nos vemos
en el próximo vídeo